jean de gliniasty bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions qu'est ce qu'on
peut attendre de ces législatives
anticipées est ce qui a déjà une
tendance qui se dégage oui il ya une
tendance qui se dégage à savoir qu' il
n'y en a pas vraiment et que en fait il
ya un quart des internautes des
intentions de vote pour pashinian un
quart des intentions de vote à peu près
pour coacher rien donc il n'est pas
exclu qu'il ya un deuxième tour
les lois électorales l'arménienne sont
assez contraignante il sauf que
l'alliance majoritaire est au moins 54 %
des mandats et donc ça sera une élection
très disputée élections disputées dans
les yeux est-ce que c'est pas être une
élection disputée dans la rue également
en fonction des résultats ce que des
tensions sont à craindre
à erevan la capitale notamment ce n'est
pas exclue dans la mesure où la décision
même de tenir ces élections anticipées
puisque normalement le l'échéance des
élections c'était en 2023 a été prise
par pashinian après une séquence
ininterrompue de manifestations contre
manifestation est mise en cause devant
les tribunaux de certaines personnalités
donc on est sorti de cette période de
trouble parle annonce des élections
anticipées par la décision de pachinian
d'expédier les affaires courantes entre
avril et juin
et donc il n'est pas exclu que si c'est
les élections sont très disputés il y
est encore en effet des manifestations
l'arménie c'est un petit pays coincé
entre l'iran la turquie la russie et
l'azerbaïdjan
quelles conséquences géopolitiques
pourront ces législatives surtout sept
mois après le conflit armé dans le
haut-karabagh évidemment le sujet sous
jacents de ces élections c'est la
défaite
de l'arménie et l'accord 9 décembre
dernier qui a été enregistrée si je puis
dire par la russie qui est contesté par
une grande partie des arméniens donc je
risque est que en cas de victoire des
contestataires de l'accord du 10
décembre qui ne sont pas exactement ceux
qui critiquent pas si lyon pour sa
défaite il y a il ya des marges mais si
par une coach et riant même même s'il
n'a pas dit dans son programme qu'il
allait remettre en cause d'accords du 2
décembre
il n'en reste pas moins que gauthier
rien qui est lui-même karabatic est né
au karabakh qui a bâti son image
politique sur une une
une idée de dureté de résistance face à
l'azerbaïdjan risque de remettre en
cause l'accord soit directement soit
indirectement
il est à noter que l'azerbaïdjan la
turquie en tout cas discrètement
s'inquiètent de l'avenir de l'accord et
laisse entendre que baba chinian
finalement c'est plus prévisible ça veut
dire que si robert kotcharian s'impose
et il pourrait y avoir de nouveaux
troubles de nouveaux heurts dans le sud
caucase dans le haut-karabagh c'est
difficile à dire parce que coach et rien
se fera élire sur une image de fermeté
de dureté mais c'est un homme politique
il a été président pendant 10 entre 98
et 2008
c'est un homme qui sera je pense gérait
s'il est élu la situation mais il faudra
quelque part qu'il qu'il montre qu' il
n'est pas ma xin yang que lui il est
plus dur et qu'il résiste aux pressions
internationales nikol pashinian de son
côté il était populaire au moment de son
arrivée au pouvoir est ce que le conflit
du haut karabagh explique à lui seul
cette baisse de popularité qu'est ce qui
différencie au fond les deux hommes
repèrent tout cas charriant qui lui fut
rompue aux joutes politiciennes
bien pashinian effectivement s'est fait
élire sur le thème de la lutte contre la
corruption
l'assainissement des institutions et je
pense que ce capital il a quand même en
gros préserver je crois que l'essentiel
de son affaiblissement tient à la
défaite dans le haut karabakh
vous disiez tout à l'heure un car a
priori pour l'un un kart pour l'autre du
coup il reste une autre moitié
qu'est ce que cette population-là
va-t-elle voter est ce que la population
arménienne est divisée voire fracturée
avant avancer ces législatives
anticipées
oui parce que le système le système
législatifs et constitutionnels arménien
est assez complexe
en fait il donne la primeur aux
alliances et puis il ya beaucoup de
petits partis et en scène on sert le
gouvernement jusqu'aux quais les deux
parties ne peut s et réalise tout seul
gars ou l'alliance qu'il aura constitué
de gagner les élections
donc ce sont des petits partis comme par
exemple celle de l'honneur ou arménie
lumineuse à faire des choses comme ça
n'est pas comme ça qu'ils vont en fait
décidé du gagnant soit au terme du
premier tour au terme du deuxième et
donc ces petits partis dans l'ensemble
font plutôt opposés à pashinian donc
vraiment les chances sont très partagés
selon la victoire de l'un ou de l'autre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre des
déclarations à l'international des
messages de félicitations de
condamnation et quelle suite pour
l'avenir l'international dans cette
région c'est difficile à dire je pense
que la majorité enfin la communauté
internationale dans son ensemble passe
après que l'accord du du 10 décembre
soit maintenu et donc c'est ça la
préoccupation principale
exprimons les messages de félicitations
au moment de l'élection du nouveau
président donc ça sera plus naturel
évidemment 24 pashinian est un petit peu
plus
si je puis dire dans le cas de de
l'élection de kotcharian
merci beaucoup jean de gliniasty d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste de la région du
caucase vous êtes directeur de recherche
à l'iris institut des relations
internationales stratégiques puis vous
est également l'auteur de l' ouvrage
intitulé petite histoire des relations
franco russes aux éditions d'inventaire